what up space fam goes in here for anime
uproar and today we're going to be
talking about the guy who seemed like a
big jerk in the beginning but ended up
being one of the most touching
characters in the series you guys voted
for him via the Instagram story at anime
out floor so make sure to stay tuned
because we're going to be looking at
exactly how strong the very impressive
wind pillar sanam II truly is I said
that I'd make this video if we got 5,000
likes on the previous video and we did
so here I am hard at work as promised
I'm psyched about the fact that you guys
like this series so much this is already
the tenth installment of the Demon
Slayer how strong is series and I'm
blown away at how well all the previous
videos did to keep the uninterrupted
train of videos going make sure to smash
that like button and share this video
with a friend that really helps out once
we get 5,000 likes on this video I will
start on the next one ASAP if you
haven't be sure to subscribe and this is
absolutely crucial hit that notification
bell because you'll have no clue when
future demons their videos come out if
you don't as usual you can vote for who
the next Demon Slayer video will be
about via our Instagram story at anime
up roar the stories only last for 24
hours so make sure to vote before it's
too late
we do these votes every time so make
sure you're following us on instagram at
anime out drawer so you can help decide
what videos i make next obviously there
will be manga spoilers in this video i'm
going to be looking at all of the
evidence to determine exactly how strong
economy is so if spoilers actually
bother you you've been warned now
without further ado let's jump into it
son of me or as I like to call him older
jerk bro with a heart of gold had a
tragic backstory like almost every demon
Slayer
let's take a look at a specific one now
which will help us see the trajectory of
Sodom ease power sudden we had a small
hard-working mother who seemed to work
without sleep
their father was horrible he was big and
he would often hit his wife and his kids
despite her small size and the father's
big size the mother would always try to
protect her children from him without
hesitation
ganya and probably his big brother son
of me thought she was amazing
however their father was hated by
everyone and it didn't surprise anyone
when he got stabbed to death after their
father's death sodomy and ganya made a
to each other that they would protect
their mother and the rest of their
family together
tragically though this wasn't meant to
be one day something comes into the
house and starts killing son and me
siblings five siblings everyone but
Kenya and sana me are killed at first
Kenya thinks that it must have been a
wolf but the wolf is actually the mother
again he loves she's been turned into a
demon son he comes in and tells ganga to
run away as he tackles his demon mother
through the window while kenya is
running to go get a doctor
he runs into sana me who was covered in
blood their mom is laying at his feet
Kenya doesn't know what's going on so he
starts to call sana me a murderer who'd
kill his own mother in truth Kenya is
only alive because sana me risked his
life in order to stop their demon mother
he got the prominent scars on his face
from this fight obviously it was
probably the hardest thing sodomy ever
had to do in his life and after it's
finally complete he even has to be
called a murderer by the little brother
he saved son amis backstory is arguably
the most tragic of all sana me turned
cold towards Kenya but it was done to
protect him he always loved his little
brother he was the most important person
in his life so he always discouraged him
from becoming a Demon Slayer because he
wanted him to be safe he insulted him
acted like a jerk to him and told him
that he had no talent because he wanted
him to live a normal safe life while
sana me protected him from any demons
that may try to hurt him but I'm getting
ahead of myself at first son of me left
Kenya after he killed his mother the
colors in the world rapidly became worn
and faded he wandered through the night
in desperation he eventually notices
that his blood is special it slows down
demons and that is one of the ways he
was able to beat his demon mom at such a
young age son amis story is pretty crazy
he didn't even know anything about demon
slayers and each stream blades when he
started hunting demons on his own he
armed himself with a mountain of blades
fought demons caught them and then use
sunlight to burn them to death
that's absolutely insane if you think
about it according to Sun and me it was
like he wanted to commit suicide he kept
lodging himself at dangerous demons but
he didn't die son of me thinks he was
lucky because his blood intoxicated
demons however he's being too modest
his blood definitely helped but you have
to be super skilled to kill demons
a young age with no Nichiren blades or
knowledge about demon Slayers and their
methods eventually Sonny met a member of
the demons Air Corps named masa chika
kuma no the two of them were strong
enough to kill a lower moon one demon
but masa chika died in the process it's
significant that son and me not only
helped defeat the strongest slower moon
so early on but he even survived the
demon Slayers were so impressed that
they promoted side of me to a pillar at
first time he was upset with a demon
slayer leader kagaya
Yui Isshiki he didn't like how kagaya
smiles and issues orders while other
people are the ones risking their lives
the other pillars are upset with son
amis behavior and disrespect but oubli
Isshiki is not he lets enemy talk and
insult him after son he finishes with
his verbal lashing with his insult
cocktail oubli Isshiki simply apologizes
he explains that he tried swinging a
sword but it was no use
he was too weak he apologizes that he
has to ask the demon slayers to do such
difficult and dangerous things
hoo-boy ishiki looks at sunnah me like
an affectionate parent he says that if
the demon Slayers are pawns then he's a
sacrificial piece to the leader says he
only wants enemy to protect people as a
pillar Bui Isshiki apologizes for
summoning sana me soon after his friend
masa chicas death he knows that they
were close like brothers suddenly
surprised it will be a sheikh he knows
so much and then Connie reveals that the
leader has memorized all the names and
backgrounds of Dimas heirs who have died
this info leaves sana me stunned and he
starts to respect oh boy Isshiki from
this point on we are chief he gives son
and me his friends will and explains
that all demon stares want the same
thing for their loved ones to smile live
happily until the day they die and to
never have their lives cruelly
threatened even if they can't stay by
their side this is a powerful moment and
I'm not surprised that son and me got a
reality check and changed his behavior
towards Yui ishiki after this now let's
get to some more challenging fights that
can give us a better sense of what side
of me is capable of right now sin amis
most challenging result fight to date
has been against Coco Chabot but the
fight against moves on is sure to be
even more challenging nevertheless we
can learn a lot about side of me by
analyzing his role during the
fight against upper moon one kakushi bow
the demon brother of the strongest demon
seer in history yah Ichi muy Chino the
extremely talented miss pillar is the
first one who runs into Kakashi bow he
immediately notices that upper moon one
can't be compared to any of the other
upper moons that's saying a lot because
upper moon Akasa and upper moon dolma
we're near impossible to overcome and
this guy supposed to be so strong that
he can't even be compared to them
Kakashi bow makes pretty quick work of
mochi doe which speaks to upper moon
ones strength because mu Ichiro is
arguably the most naturally talented
pillar even though he lacks experience
since he's only 14 years old at the time
to get even more info on just how
impressive muy tuna is make sure to
check out our how strong is mu Ichiro
video which I'll link in the description
and at the end of this video however for
this video all you need to know is that
mu Ichiro is super strong and kokeshi
bow overpowers him like it's nothing as
soon as the upper moon draws his sword
he takes mu Ichiro's hand off mu Ichiro
tries to keep fighting by Coco she will
easily pins him to a beam using mu
Ichiro's own sword
the young pillar even has a manifested
demon Aramark at this point but kuku she
bo stops him so easily
then ganea shows up and gets quickly
rekt just as kokeshi bow is about to
kill ganya suddenly swoops in to rescue
his little brother in the nick of time
he then tells his little brother that he
should have had a house somewhere and
raised the family and grown old suddeniy
wanted him to have a happy wife and
children and sana me would have never
let a demon get near his little brother
then an outrage sana me screams angrily
a Kakashi bow for hurting his little
brother at this point their fight begins
son of me does considerably better than
mu Ichigo suggesting that at this point
he's stronger than mu ichigo was at the
beginning of the fight cuckoos evil
comments at house on amis physical
techniques are at their peak after
seeing kakushi bow and his moon
breathing in action suddeniy is not
surprised that Moishe too lost he admits
that he couldn't survive if his senses
hadn't been honed from long experience
he's got at least 7 years worth of
experience on mu Ichiro after all when
Sonny sees how strong Kakashi bow is he
doesn't get scared rather he gets
excited by the challenge saying that
Kakashi bow is a demon worth killing
what a boss Sunday me cuts into
she bows blade with his attacks he gets
close and attacks fukushi bow who blocks
the sword attack with his own sword
however son of me has a back-up plan
he's holding another sword with his foot
and he brings it up to try to stab
kokeshi bow but the upper moon dodges
that attack - cuckoo she was impressed
by how well son of me keeps up with his
technique
it makes him nostalgic and it makes him
want to try harder suggesting that Sunmi
is the strongest opponent he's fought
against in a while finally though
hakushi bow launches a powerful attack
that badly once enemy and leaves him cut
all over Koko she was sure that if Sonny
moves his insides will spill out and
he'll die however son he takes advantage
of the fact that his blood intoxicates
demons and unexpectedly attacks kakushi
bow sunday me was able to stop the
bleeding himself he uses breathing and
flexes his muscles to stop his guts from
spilling out kuku she was surprised
saying that any other pillar he fought
before would have been killed by those
injuries nevertheless kokeshi bow gets
the upper hand again but sana me is
seemingly never out of ideas and when
koko she bow steps on his sword son of
me takes out a gun and shoots kokeshi
bow in the face
kuku she will blocks the bullets with a
sword he launches a finishing attack but
Yomi shows up saving sana me
yo made the strongest pillar tell son of
me to stitch up his stomach wound while
he holds off kakushi bow not
surprisingly Yomi does better than both
mu Ichigo and son of me
he even succeeds in breaking Coco's evil
sword unfortunately it just regenerates
quickly yo man keeps fighting while sana
me is tending to his wounds and san amis
own demon slayer mark appears on his
right cheek he joins a fight to help
Yomi
sana me and yo may perhaps make the most
formidable tag team they trained
together as pillars so they can
cooperate during high speed battles it's
impressive that anyone can keep up with
Guillaume a and suddenly manages to do
it for a time Coco she bow can't help
but think that these two meeting Yomi
and son of me are highly skilled
even among the pillars Gugu she bow
tries to kill Santa me the weaker link
butts enemies reflexes speed and
accuracy increase allowing him to repel
focal she was attack and keep the upper
moon from breaking his sword yo may
succeeds in taking Cobra she bows ear
off and that's when kokeshi bow catches
them off guard his sword increases in
length
drastically increasing the strength and
range of
tax suddenly lost some fingers from this
attack but it could have been worse
Gill may used his chain to alter the
angle of attack and in doing so saved
Sunday me from losing both of his arms
Sunim II was not quick enough to respond
like yo may sana me eventually admits
that the more damage he takes the slower
he gets and the more he holds gilma back
sana me keeps taking damage and tells
Chioma to forget about him it seems like
it's the end for sana me until Muay
cheetah saves him then three pillars and
ganya work together to stop kakushi beau
yo may uses a bead to create an opening
the three work together and yo Mei is
able to take one of Koko she bows arms
and mu Ichiro is able to stab him with
his blade eventually Mui chinos blade
turns red and this spells the beginning
of the end for Kakashi bo yo may and Sun
and me go on to take off his head
suddeniy hits down on Gil May's wrecking
ball the weapons turn red and there's
enough force to take off Koko she bows
head the head grows back and Koko shiva
becomes a monster but eventually the
wound mu Ichigo gave him combined with
his own doubts about what he's become
lead to his downfall
by the time kakushi beau disappears
sunny has been pushed so hard that he's
passed out he is fighting unconsciously
yo may thinks it's unbelievable how he
kept moving despite losing consciousness
and has to calm him down
despite the insane amount of damage he's
taken sodomy survives unfortunately his
little brother does not and this leads
to one of the most touching moments in
the series sunnymeade the big jerk with
the tough murderous exterior can't help
a cry for his brother
Kenya even calls him the sweetest person
in the world sana me begs God not to
take his brother and screams out in
anguish but gilma interrupts him since
they have no time to grieve they have to
go and defeat Mouzon not only the son of
me survived
he's even battle ready by chapter 185 he
manages to sneak up on Mouzon and he
cuts him in half vertically he has a
determined expressionless look on his
face
initially it kind of reminds me of
tantos non-self state that he used to
cut off on kisses head but that is
likely a coincidence after all sana me
definitely doesn't seem like he's given
up his killing intent in fact he seems
determined to get his revenge he uses
bottles of flammable liquids to set
Mouzon on fire
Musa loses his cool showing how talented
son
he is few could bother moves on as much
as he does and he's coming off fighting
upper moon one and that is what's
happened so far although we may get to
see more significant things as the
battle rages on
suddenly in my view is as Coco she will
notice one of the strongest pillars he
is clearly not as strongest Gil may as
we saw during the Coco Shiva fight but
he could arguably survive even worse
wounds than Gil may could his
regenerative and recovering power for a
human is legendary
the only other pillar who could be said
to approach sodomy and skill at this
point is mu Ichiro right before he died
as we saw Sonny was more effective
against Goku she bow and put up a better
fight than mu ichi know that in the
beginning however mu Ichigo gained
access to the sea through world later
and his weapon was the first to turn red
he managed to get his sword into Kakashi
bow while sodomy did not for these
reasons I think a case can be made that
later on in the fight Muay judo could
have surpassed son of me however
surpassing son of me cost him his life
while son of me survived and as a result
will continue to grow stronger I think
Muay chiloe was insanely talented and
it's a tragedy that he died but luckily
Sonny me survived and there's little
doubt that he'll surpass where mu Ichiro
was at during the moves on fight if he
hasn't already it's also gonna be
interesting to see Igor the snake pillar
giving us all and see where he stands
among all the other pillars still it's
not everyone that can sneak up on Luzon
and make him lose his cool son of me is
not only strong he's also the most
durable and his versatile and tricky
attacks make him a force to be reckoned
with you never know what he's going to
do next and that can make him even more
difficult to predict than gilman in the
end now that mu Ichiro is gone
son of me definitely seems to be the
closest pillar to Gil Mays level and
since his damage tolerance seems to be
practically infinite he'll probably
survive and continue to get stronger and
stronger overall I think Sanne me is
definitely stronger than ton zero most
of the time what I'll ask you guys how
do you think Sonny would fare against
time zero in that non self state that he
used to cut off all kisses head
obviously punch up couldn't maintain
that state for long but I'd pay to watch
the two go at it at their best leave
your thoughts in the comments below and
that is it for today's video if you
liked make sure to smash that like
button and share this video with a
friend remember as soon as we hit 5,000
I will start on the next one ASAP you
can go for the next video via Instagram
stories at anime uproar if you haven't
be sure to subscribe and this is crucial
hit that notification bell because you
won't know when the next Demon Slayer
video comes out if you don't a special
thank you goes out to our patrons on
patreon who help us survive YouTube
issues and who helped make videos like
this one possible I especially want to
thank our pro hero tier patrons the one
and only Gilgamesh nothing but a fan
Jason Wilson Kings ell dress fitted ala
beat Anatole kazansky alpha do angel
crews and team Sparky 65 and are the one
tier patrons the ones who stand atop all
clans Steven n grata a lull on attend
Maddie Mac 239 makoto-kun the world
stealers Tyson Kirino and the school bus
thank you all so much
if you enjoy our work you can support
more of it by going over to patreon comm
anime out Pro and becoming a patron
today for as little as $1 if you do so
you'll get your name featured in future
videos alongside these amazing people
right here and you'll even get access to
her private patron only discord where we
talk about anime life and of course dank
memes so check out patreon.com/lenguin
see you space cowboy
[Music]
you
[Music]